This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vidadhu. Last year, my family and I took a vacation to Alaska. This was a much needed, long planned break. The best part? I got to walk on the top of a glacier. The pale blue ice was translucent. Sharp ridges opened up into crevices dozens of feet deep. Every geological feature, every hill, every valley, was sculpted in ice.
这里是 Hidden Brain，我是香卡·维达姆。去年，我和家人去阿拉斯加度假。这是一次期待已久、亟需放松的假期。最棒的部分是什么？我得以在一座冰川的顶部行走。淡蓝色的冰体晶莹剔透。锋利的冰脊裂开，形成数十英尺深的冰隙。每一个地质景观，每一座山丘，每一条山谷，都是由冰雕琢而成的。
It was a sunny day and I spotted a small stream of melted water. I got on the ground and drank some. I wondered how long this water had remained frozen. The little stream is not the only ice that's melting in Alaska. The Mendenhall Glacier, one of the chief tourist attractions in Juneau, has retreated over one and a half miles in the last half century. Today you can only see a small sliver of the glacier's tongue from a lookout. I caught up with John Neary, a forest service official who tries to explain to visitors the scale of the changes that they're
那是一个晴朗的日子，我发现了一条细小的融水溪流。我趴在地上喝了一些。我琢磨着这水究竟被冻结了多久。这条小溪并不是阿拉斯加唯一在融化的冰。门登霍尔冰川是朱诺的主要旅游景点之一，在过去半个世纪里已经退缩了超过一英里半。如今，你从观景台上只能看到冰川舌的一小部分。我遇到了约翰·尼里（John Neary），他是一名林务局官员，正试图向游客们解释他们亲眼目睹的
witnessing. I would say that right now we're looking at a glacier that's filling up out of our 180 degree view we have. We're looking at maybe 10 or 15 degrees of it. Whereas if we stood in the same place 100 years ago, it would have filled up about 160 degrees of our view. You are kidding, 160 degrees of our view? Exactly, that's the reality of how big this was. And it's been retreating up this valley at about 40 or 50 feet a year, most recently
变化的规模。我想说的是，现在我们看到的冰川，在我们拥有的一百八十度视野里，它正逐渐填满。我们看到的可能只占其中的十度或十五度。然而，如果我们一百年前站在同一个地方，它会占据我们大约一百六十度视野。你在开玩笑吧，一百六十度视野？没错，这就是它曾经有多么庞大的现实。它正以每年大约四十到五十英尺的速度向这条山谷上方退缩，最近
400 feet of you. And even more dramatically recently is the thinning and the narrowing as it's just sort of collapsed in on itself in the bottom of this valley. Instead of dominating much of the valley and being able to see white eyes out a large portion of the landscape it's now becoming this little ridden that's that's at the bottom here. John is a quiet soft spoken man. recent years, as he's watched the glacier literally recede before his eyes, he started to speak up. Not just about what's happening, but what it means. But as I was chatting with John, a visitor came up to talk to him. The man said he used to
达到了四百英尺。而最近更戏剧性的变化是变薄和变窄，因为它就像是在这座山谷的底部开始自行崩塌。它没有主导大部分山谷，也无法再让人们在大部分风景中看到耀眼的白色，而是变成了现在位于谷底的一小条沟壑。约翰是一个安静、说话温和的人。近年来，当他看着冰川在眼前实实在在地退缩时，他开始发声。不仅是为了正在发生的事，也是为了这背正意味着什么。但正当我与约翰交谈时，一位游客走过来跟他说话。这个人说他曾经
serve in the Air Force and had last seen the Mendenhall Glacier a quarter century ago. There was a look in the man's eyes. It was a combination of all and horror. How could this have happened, the man asked John, why is this happening? In many ways people don't want to grasp the reality. It's a scary reality to try to grasp.
在空军服役，上一次看到门登霍尔冰川还是在四分之一世纪前。这个人的眼神里流露出一丝神情。那是敬畏与惊恐的交织。这怎么可能发生呢？这个人问约翰，为什么会这样？在很多情况下，人们并不想去正视现实。这是一个试图去正视时让人感到害怕的现实。
And so what they naturally want to do is assume, well, this has always happened, it will happen in the future and will survive, won't we? They want an assurance from me. But I don't give it to them. I don't think it's my job to give them that assurance. I think they need to grasp the reality of the fact that we are entering into a time when yes, glacial advance in retreat has happened 25 different times to North America over its long life, but never at the rate
因此，他们自然而然想做的事情就是假设，嗯，这以前一直都在发生，未来也会发生，我们会挺过去的，不是吗？他们想要从我这里得到一个保证。但我不会给他们。我不认为给我这种保证是我的工作。我认为他们需要正视这样一个事实，即我们正在进入这样一个时期：是的，在北美漫长的生命中，冰川的前进与退缩已经发生过25次之多，但从未像现在这样以我们所见的
and the scale that we see now. And in the very quick rapidity of it means that species probably won't be able to adapt the way that they have in the past over a longer period of time. To be clear, the Mendenhall Glacier's retreat in and of itself is not proof of climate change. That evidence comes from a range of scientific measurements and calculations. But the glacier is a visible symbol of the changes
速度和规模发生。而且它发生得如此之快，这意味着物种可能无法像过去那样在较长时期内进行适应。需要明确的是，门登霍尔冰川的退缩本身并不是气候变化的证据。这些证据来自于一系列的科学测量和计算。但这座冰川是科学家们正在记录的
that scientists are documenting. It's interesting, I think, when people think about climate change, it tends to be an abstract issue most of the time for most people that you're standing in front of this magnificent glacier right now and to actually see it receding makes it feel real and visceral in a way that it just isn't when I'm living in Washington, DC. Oh, I agree. I think that for too many people the issue is some Micronesian island that's having an
变化的视觉化象征。我认为这很有意思，当人们想到气候变化时，对大多数人来说，大多数时候它往往是一个抽象的问题，而你现在正站在这个宏伟的冰川前，亲眼看着它退缩，这让它变得真实而直观，而在我住在华盛顿特区时，这种感觉是绝对没有的。哦，我同意。我认为对太多人来说，这个问题是某个密克罗尼西亚岛屿，今年他们的海岸线上面临着
extra inch of water this year on their shorelines, or it's some polar bears far up in the Arctic that they're really not connected with. But when they realize they come here, and they're on this nice day, like we're experienced right now with the warm sun, they start to think about this glacier melting and why it's receding, why it's disappearing, why it doesn't look like that photo,
多出一英寸的水，或者是北极深处的一些北极熊，他们与这些熊并没有真正的联系。但当他们意识到自己来到这里，在这个美好的日子里，就像我们现在经历的这样，有着温暖的阳光，他们开始思考这座冰川为什么在融化，为什么在退缩，为什么在消失，为什么它看起来不像那张照片
just 30 years ago up in the visitor center, it becomes real for them, and they have to start grapple with the issues behind it. I could see tourists turning these questions over in their minds as they watch the glacier. So even though I had not planned to do any reporting, I started interviewing people using the only device I had available, my phone. This is Dale Singer. She and her family came to Alaska on a cruise to celebrate a couple of family birthdays. This was her second trip to Mendenhall.
就在游客中心里三十年前的照片那样，这对他们来说就变得真实了，他们不得不开始应对背后的问题。我可以看到游客们在看着冰川时，脑海中正在反复琢磨这些问题。所以，尽管我本来没打算做任何报道，我还是开始用我手头唯一的设备——我的手机采访人们。这是戴尔·辛格。她和家人乘游轮来到阿拉斯加，是为了庆祝几个家庭成员的生日。这是她第二次来门登霍尔。
She came about nine years ago, but the weather was so foggy, she couldn't get a good look. She felt compelled to come back. I asked Dale why she thought the glacier was retreating. Global warming, whether we like to admit it or not, it's our fault. Or something we're doing is effect and climate change. Others are not so sure. For some of Dale's fellow passengers on her cruise, this is a touchy topic. Somebody just said they went to a lecture on the ship and the lecturer did not use the word global warming nor
她大约九年前来过，但当时雾太大了，她没能看清楚。她觉得非得回来看看不可。我问戴尔为什么她认为冰川在退缩。全球变暖，不管我们愿意承认与否，这是我们的错。或者我们正在做的某事正在影响和改变气候。其他人则没有那么确定。对于戴尔游轮上的某些同伴来说，这是一个敏感的话题。
climate change because he didn't want to offend passengers. So there are still people who refuse to admit it. As I was standing next to John, one man carefully came up and listened to his account of the science of climate change. When John was done talking, the man told him that he wouldn't trust scientists as far as he could throw them.
刚刚有人说，他们去听了一场船上的讲座，讲师没有使用“全球变暖”或“气候变化”这两个词，因为他不想冒犯乘客。所以仍然有人拒绝承认这一点。当我站在约翰旁边时，一个男子小心翼翼地走过来，听他讲述关于气候变化的科学。当约翰讲完后，这男子告诉他，对于科学家，他说什么都不会去相信。
Climate change was all about politics, he said. I asked the man for an interview, but he declined. He said his company had contracts with the federal government, and of bureaucrats in the Obama administration heard his skeptical views on climate change, those contracts might mysteriously disappear. I caught up with another tourist. I asked Michael Bull, if he believed climate change was real.
他说，气候变化完全是政治。我向这名男子请求采访，但他拒绝了。他说他的公司与联邦政府有合同，如果奥巴马政府的官僚们听到他对气候变化的怀疑观点，那些合同可能会神秘地消失。我遇到了另一位游客。我问迈克尔·布尔，他是否相信气候变化是真实的。
No, I think there's global climate change, but I question whether it's all due to human interaction with the earth. Yes, you can't deny the thing that climate is changing. Yeah, but the causation of that, I'm not sold on as being our fault. Michael was worried his tour bus might leave without him, so he answered my question about whether the Glacier's retreat was cause or alarm, standing next to the idling bus. So what's the bad part of the Glacier receiving? And you know, from what John said to me, if it's the rate at which and the Earth can't adapt, that makes sense to me.
不，我认为存在全球气候变化，但我怀疑这是否全都是人类与地球相互作用造成的。是的，你不能否认气候正在改变这一事实。是的，但对于其中的因果关系，我不认为那是我们的错。迈克尔担心他的旅游巴士不等他就开走了，所以他站在正在怠速的巴士旁，回答了我关于冰川退缩是否是祸是福的问题。那么，冰川退缩的坏处是什么呢？你知道的，从约翰对我说的话来看，如果它是以人类无法适应的速度在进行，那这对我来说是有道理的。
But I think the final story is yet to be written. Yeah, I think mother earth pushes back So I don't think we're gonna destroy her because I think she'll take care of us before we take care of The Nugget Falls is a beautiful waterfall that empties into Mendenhall Lake. When John first came to Alaska in 1982, the waterfall was adjacent to the glacier. Today there is a gap of three quarters of a mile between the waterfall and the glacier. The glacier has receded unbelievably. It's quite shocking. This is Sue Schultz. She said she lived in June or back in the 1980s. This was her first time back in 28 years.
但我认为最终的故事尚未写就。是的，我认为地球母亲会进行反击，所以我不认为我们会毁灭她，因为我认为在我们照顾她之前，她会先照顾我们。纳金瀑布（Nugget Falls）是一个美丽的瀑布，注入门登霍尔湖。1982年约翰刚来到阿拉斯加时，瀑布与冰川是相邻的。而如今，瀑布与冰川之间存在着四分之三英里的空隙。冰川退缩得令人难以置信。这相当震撼。这是苏·舒尔茨。她说她曾在20世纪80年代住在朱诺。这是她时隔28年第一次回来。
What did it look like 28 years ago? The bear rock that you see to the left, as you face the glacier, was glacier. And we used to hike on the other side of it. You could take a trail right onto the glacier. And what about this way? I understand the glacier actually came significantly over to this side close to nugget falls. Yes, that's true. It was really close. In fact, the lake was a lot smaller, obviously. I mean, yeah, it's quite incredible.
28年前这里是什么样子的？当你面对冰川时，你看到左边的那些光秃秃的岩石，曾经都是冰川。我们过去常常在它的另一边远足。你可以沿着一条小径直接走到冰川上。那这边呢？我听说冰川实际上曾显著地延伸到这一侧，靠近纳金瀑布。是的，这是真的。它真的很近。事实上，湖泊明显要小得多。我是说，是的，这相当不可思议。
And so, what's your reaction when you see it? Global warming. We need to pay attention. Even if it all melts, it's not going to be the end of the world. So I'm not worried. Terry Lambert is a tourist from Southern California. He's never visited Mendenhall before. He thinks the melting glacier is just part of nature's plan. While it's just like earthquakes and floods and hurricanes. There are just all part of what's going on. You can't control it, you can't change it. I personally
那么，当你看到它时，你的反应是什么？全球变暖。我们需要予以重视。即使它全部融化了，也不会是世界末日。所以我并不担心。特里·兰伯特是来自南加州的游客。他以前从未参观过门登霍尔。他认为冰川融化只是自然计划的一部分。嗯，它就像地震、洪水和飓风一样。这些都只是正在发生的事情的一部分。你无法控制它，你也无法改变它。我个人
don't think it's something that man's doing that's making that melt. I mentioned to Terry some of the possible consequences of climate change on various species. Well, there could be changes, some species could be advantage, some species could be disadvantage, the ecosystem is changing, you're going to have flooding, you could have weather events, right? There could be consequences that affect you and I. Yes, but like I said so far in the future, I'm not worried about it. I realized at that moment that the debate over climate change is no longer really about science unless the science you're talking about is the study of human behavior.
不认为这是人类在做的事情导致了冰川融化。我向特里提到了气候变化对各个物种的一些可能影响。好吧，可能会有变化，一些物种可能会占优势，一些物种可能会处于劣势，生态系统正在改变，你会有洪水，你可能会遭遇极端天气事件，对吧？可能会产生影响你和我的后果。是的，但就像我说的，那是很遥远未来的事，我并不担心。我当时意识到，关于气候变化的争论实际上已经不再关乎科学，除非你所说的科学是对人类行为的研究。
I asked John why he thought so many people were unwilling to accept the scientific consensus that climate change was having real consequences. The inability to do anything about it themselves, because it's threatening to think about giving up your car, giving up your oil heater in your house, or giving up many of the things that you become accustomed to, they seem very threatening to them. And really, I've looked at some of the brain science actually and talked to folks at NASA, and North and Sky, and they've actually talked about how, when that fear becomes overriding for people, they use a part of their brain.
我问约翰，为什么他认为这么多人不愿意接受“气候变化正在产生真实后果”这一科学共识。因为他们自己对此无能为力，因为想到要放弃你的汽车、放弃你家里的燃油暖气，或者放弃许多你已经习以为常的东西，这让他们感到非常具有威胁性。实际上，我研究过一些脑科学，并与美国宇航局（NASA）以及“北方天空”（North and Sky）的人们交流过，他们实际上谈到了当这种恐惧对人们来说变得压倒一切时，他们会使用大脑的一部分。
That's the very primitive part that has to react. It has to instantly come to a conclusion so that it can lead to an action. Whereas what we need to think about is get rid of that fear and start thinking logically, start thinking creatively, allow a different part of the brain to kick in, and really think how we as humans can reverse this trend that we've caused. Coming up, we explore why the human brain might not be well designed to grapple with the threat of climate change, and what we can do about it. Stay with us. This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedantam.
那是必须做出反应的非常原始的那一部分。它必须瞬间得出结论，以便能够付诸行动。而我们需要思考的是摆脱这种恐惧，开始进行逻辑思考，开始进行创造性思考，让大脑的不同部分发挥作用，并真正思考我们人类如何才能扭转我们所造成的这种趋势。接下来，我们将探讨为什么人类大脑可能并不适合应对气候变化的威胁，以及我们能做些什么。请继续收听。这里是 Hidden Brain，我是香卡·韦达姆。
While visiting the Menton Hall Glacier with my family last year, I started thinking more and more about the intersection between climate change and human behavior. When I got back to Washington DC, I called George Marshall. He's an environmentalist who, like John Neary, tries to educate people about global climate change. I am the founder of Climate Outreach and I am the author of Don't Even Think About It. Why our brains are wired to ignore climate change. the author or don't even think about it, why our brains are wired to ignore climate change. As the book's title suggests, George believes that the biggest roadblock in the battle against climate change may lie inside the human brain. I call George at his home in Wales.
去年我和家人访问门登霍尔冰川时，我开始越来越多地思考气候变化与人类行为之间的交集。回到华盛顿特区后，我打电话给乔治·马歇尔。他是一位环保主义者，和约翰·尼里一样，致力于向人们普及全球气候变化的知识。我是 Climate Outreach 的创始人，也是《想都别想：为什么我们的大脑生来就会忽视气候变化》一书的作者。作者是《想都别想：为什么我们的大脑生来就会忽视气候变化》。正如书名所示，乔治认为对抗气候变化的最大障碍可能存在于人类大脑内部。我在威尔士的家中给乔治打了电话。
You spend some time talking with Daniel Kahneman, the famous psychologist who won the Nobel Prize in Economics, and he actually presented a very pessimistic view that we would actually come to terms with the threat of climate change. He said to me that we are as humans, very poor at dealing with issues, whether in the future we tend to be very focused on a short term, we tend to discount, would be the economic term, to reduce the value of things happening in the future of a further away they are. He says we're very cost diverse, that's the first to say, when there is a reward we respond strongly but when there's a cost we prefer to push it away just as I myself would try and leave until the very last minute, you have been in my tax return, I mean you just don't want to deal with these things. And he says, but we're reluctant to deal with uncertainty. If things are uncertain, we, or we perceive them to be,
你花了一些时间与丹尼尔·卡尼曼交谈，这位获得诺贝尔经济学奖的著名心理学家，他实际上提出了一个非常悲观的观点，即我们是否会真正正视气候变化的威胁。他对我说，作为人类，我们在处理问题时非常糟糕，无论是在未来，我们往往高度关注短期，我们往往会进行贴现，用经济学的术语来说，就是降低发生在未来的事情的价值，离得越远价值越低。他说我们非常厌恶成本，这是首先要说的，当有回报时我们的反应很强烈，但当有成本时我们更倾向于把它推开，就像我自己会试图拖到最后一分钟才去处理纳税申报表一样，我的意思是，你就是不想去处理这些事情。他说，但我们不愿意面对不确定性。如果事情是不确定的，或者我们认为它们是不确定的，
we just say, well, come back and tell me when they're certain. What he said to me was in his view of climate change is the worst possible combination, because it's not only in the future, but it's also in the future and uncertain, and it's in the future uncertain and involving costs. And his own experiments, and he's done many, many of these over the years, show that in this combination we have a very strong tendency just to push things on one side.
我们就会说，好吧，等它们确定了再来告诉我。他对我说，在他看来，气候变化是最糟糕的组合，因为它不仅发生在未来，而且还在未来具有不确定性，并且还在未来具有不确定性且涉及成本。他自己的实验——这些年来他做过很多很多这样的实验——表明，在这种组合下，我们有一种非常强烈的倾向，就是把事情推到一边。
And I think this in some ways explains how so many people, if you ask them, we'll say yes, I regard climate change to be a threat. But if you go and you ask them and this happens every year in surveys, what are the most important surveys, what are the most important issues, what are the strangely almost everybody seems to forget about climate change. So when we focus on it, we know it's there, but we can somehow push it away. You tell an amusing story in your book about some colleagues who are worried about a cell phone tower being erected in their neighborhood. And the very, very different reaction of these colleagues to the cell phone tower
我认为这在某种程度上解释了为什么有那么多人在被问及时代会说，是的，我认为气候变化是一个威胁。但如果你去问他们——这在每年的调查中都会发生——什么是最重要的调查，什么是最重要的问题，奇怪的是，几乎每个人似乎都忘记了气候变化。所以当我们关注它时，我们知道它在那里，但我们不知怎么地可以把它推开。你在书中讲了一个有趣的故事，关于一些同事担心在他们的社区里竖起一座手机信号塔。而这些同事对手机信号塔的反应，
than to sort of the amorphous threat of climate change. They were my neighbors, my entire community. I was living at that time in Oxford, which as many of you listen to me, I know is a university town. So I'd be like living in Harvard or Berkeley or somewhere where most of the people were in various ways involved of the university, highly educated, a mobile phone master was being set up in the middle, alongside actually a school playground, enormous outcry, everybody mobilized down the local church hall, they were all
与对气候变化那种虚无缥缈的威胁的反应截然不同。他们是我的邻居，我的整个社区。我当时住在牛津，正如你们许多听众所知，这是一个大学城。所以这就像住在哈佛、伯克利或某个地方，大多数人以各种方式与大学相关，受过高等教育，一个移动电话信号塔正在中间设立，实际上就在一个学校操场旁边，引起了巨大的抗议，每个人都动员起来到当地的教堂大厅，他们都
going to stop it, people even going to lay themselves down in front of a bulldozer to prevent it, because it was here, it was now. There was an enemy which was this external mobile phone company. We're going to come in there. We're going to put up this mask. It brings in the threat psychologists would call the absolute fear of radiation. This is what's called a dread fear. And so on.
打算阻止它，人们甚至打算躺在推土机前阻止它，因为它就在这里，就在现在。有一个敌人，就是这个外部的移动电话公司。我们要去那里。我们要竖起这个信号塔。它带来了心理学家所称的对辐射的绝对恐惧的威胁。这就是所谓的恐惧症。等等。
The science, if we go back to the core science, says that this mobile phone mask was, as far as we could possibly say harmless, you know, the amount of radiation or any kind you get off a single mobile phone mask, has never been found to have the slightest impact on anyone, but they were very mobilized. At the same time, I was trying to get them
科学，如果我们回到核心科学，表明这个移动电话信号塔，就我们所能确定的而言是无害的，你知道，你从单个移动电话信号塔获得的辐射或任何辐射量，从来没有被发现对任何人产生哪怕一丝一毫的影响，但他们被极大地动员起来了。与此同时，我正试图让他们
to attend events concerned of climate change and none of them would come. It simply didn't have those qualities. You have a very revealing anecdote in your book about the economist Thomas Shelling, who was once in a major traffic jam. So, shelling again, a Nobel Prize winning economist, and he's wondering what's going on. The traffic is moving very, very, very slowly and then they're creeping along and creeping along and half an hour along the road. They finally realize what has happened, that there's a mattress lying right in the middle of the middle lane of the road. What happens, he notices and he does the same is when they reach for mattress, people will simply drive, pass it and keep going.
参加关注气候变化的活动，但他们谁也不肯来。它根本不具备那些特质。你的书中有个非常具有启示意义的轶事，关于经济学家托马斯·谢林，他曾遇到过一次严重的交通堵塞。所以，谢林又是一位获得诺贝尔奖的经济学家，他在纳闷发生了什么事。交通移动得非常非常非常慢，然后他们慢慢地挪动，慢慢地挪动，在路上走了半个小时后。他们终于意识到发生了什么，原来马路中间的车道正中央躺着一个床垫。发生了什么，他注意到，他也一样，当他们到达床垫处时，人们只是简单地开车，从它旁边开过去，然后继续前行。
In other words, the thing that caused them to become delayed was not something that anyone was prepared to stop and remove from the road. They just leave the mattress there and then they keep driving past. Because in a way, why would they remove the mattress from the road because they have already paid the price of getting there they've already had with delay it's something where the benefit goes to other people the argument being that of course it's very hard especially when people are motivated largely through personal rewards to get them to do things it's interesting that the same narrative affects the way we talk about climate change internationally there are many countries who now say look you know I've already paid the price, I'm paying the price right now for the actions of other people, for the things that other
换句话说，导致他们延误的东西并不是任何人准备停下来并从路上移走的东西。他们只是把床垫留在那里，然后继续开车从旁边过去。因为从某种程度上说，他们为什么要从路上移走床垫呢，因为他们已经付出了到达那里的代价，他们已经经历过了延误，这是一个收益归属其他人的事情，其论点是，当然这非常困难，尤其是当人们主要受到个人奖励的驱使来让他们做事时。有趣的是，同样的叙事也影响了我们国际上讨论气候变化的方式。现在有许多国家说，听着，你知道，我已经付出了代价，我此时此刻正在为其他人的行为付出代价，为其他
people have or have not done. I'm bearing that cost, and you're asking me now to get out of my car, pull the mattress off the road, to bear an additional cost, and the only people who benefit from that are people who are not me. The collective problems in the end have personal consequences. I have to say that the way one talks about this also shows the way that interpretation is biased by your own politics or your own view. This has been labeled for a long time the tragedy of the commons. The idea being that unless people will, if it's in their own self-interest, destroy the very thing that sustains them because it's not in their personal interest to do something if they don't see other people doing it.
人做过或没有做过的事情付出代价。我正在承受那个成本，而你现在要求我下车，把床垫从路上拉开，去承担额外的成本，而唯一从中受益的人却不是我。集体问题最终会产生个人的后果。我必须说，谈论这件事的方式也表明了这种解释是如何被你自己的政治观点或你自己的看法所偏置的。长期以来，这被称为“公地悲剧”。其观点是，除非出于自身利益，否则人们会摧毁维持他们生存的东西，因为如果不看到其他人也在做某事，去做这件事就不符合他们的个人利益。
In a way it's understandable, but of course that depends on a view of a world where you see people as been motivated entirely by their own personal rewards. We often know that people are motivated by their sense of identity and their sense of belonging And we know very well. I'm not least of all in times of major conflict or war that people are prepared to make enormous personal sacrifices from which they personally enormous personal sacrifices from which they personally derive nothing except loss, but they're making that in the interests of the greater good. For a long time with climate change, we've made a mistake of talking about this solely in terms of something which is economic.
从某种意义上说这是可以理解的，但当然，这取决于这样一种世界观：你认为人们完全是由他们自己的个人奖励所驱动的。我们经常知道，人们是由他们的认同感和归属感所驱动的。我们非常清楚。尤其是在重大冲突或战争时期，人们准备做出巨大的个人牺牲，从这些牺牲中他们个人除了失去之外什么也得不到，但为了更大的利益，他们正在做出这样的牺牲。长期以来，在气候变化问题上，我们犯了一个错误，那就是完全从经济角度来谈论这件事。
What have the economic costs and what have the economic benefits, and we still do this, but of course really for motivations for why we want to act on this, is what we want to defend the world that we care about and the world we love. And we want to do so for ourselves and for the people who are going to come. So, George, there obviously is one domain in life where you can that an economist would say is not in their rational self-interest. People give up food, people give up water, people have, you know, suffer enormous're not doing it because someone says at the end of the year, I'm going to give you an extra 200 bucks in your paycheck or an extra $2,000 in your paycheck. They're doing it because they believe these are sacred values that are not negotiable.
经济成本是什么，经济收益是什么，我们现在仍然这样做，但当然，我们想要采取行动的真正动机，是我们想要捍卫我们所关心的世界和我们所热爱的世界。我们希望为自己以及即将来临的人们这样做。所以，乔治，生活中显然有一个领域，经济学家会说这不符合他们理性的自身利益。人们放弃食物，人们放弃水，人们，你知道，遭受巨大的痛苦……他们这样做并不是因为有人在年底说，我要在你的工资单上多给你200美元，或者在你的工资单上多给你2000美元。他们这样做是因为他们相信这些是不容妥协的神圣价值观。
Well, and not just economists would find those behavior strange, but Professor Kahneman will kind of pure cognitive psychology might as well, because these are people who are struggling with but also believe passionately in things which are in the long term extremely uncertain and require personal cost, and yet people do so. It's very important to stress that when we talk about climate change and religion that there's absolutely no sense at all that climate change is or can or should ever be like a religion, it's not, it's grounded in science. But we can also learn, I think, a great deal from religions about how to approach these issues, these uncertain issues, and how to create, I think, a community of shared belief
嗯，不仅经济学家会觉得这些行为奇怪，卡尼曼教授和纯粹的认知心理学可能也会觉得奇怪，因为这些人正在苦苦挣扎，但同时也坚信那些在长期内极其不确定且需要付出个人代价的事情，然而人们还是这么做了。非常重要的一点是要强调，当我们谈论气候变化和宗教时，绝没有任何意义认为气候变化是、可以或应该永远像一种宗教，它不是，它植根于科学。但我想我们也可以从宗教那里学到很多东西，关于如何处理这些问题，这些不确定问题，以及如何创造，我认为，一个共享信仰的共同体
and shared conviction that something is important. Right, I mean, if you look at sort of human history with sort of the broad view, you don't actually have to be a religious person to acknowledge that religion has played a very, very important role in the lives of millions of people over thousands of years. And if it's done so, then a scientific approach would say there is something about the nature of religious belief or the practice of religion that harnesses what our brains can accommodate,
和共同的信念，即某事是重要的。对，我的意思是，如果你用广阔的视角来看待人类历史，你其实不需要是一个有宗教信仰的人也能承认，宗教在数千年来数百万人的生活中发挥了非常非常重要的作用。如果它确实如此，那么科学的方法就会说，宗教信仰的本质或宗教的实践中，有什么东西利用了我们大脑所能容纳的东西，
that they harness our yearning to be part of a tribe, our yearning to be connected to deeper and grander values than ourselves, our yearning in some connected to deeper and grander values than ourselves are yearning in some ways to do things for our fellow person in a way that might not be tangible in the here and now but might actually pay off as you say not just for future generations but even in the hereafter. Well and the faiths that dominate the half a dozen faiths which are the strongest ones in the world are the ones that Have been best at doing that
它们利用了我们成为部落一部分的渴望，我们与比自身更深邃、更宏伟的价值观建立联系的渴望，我们在某种程度上为同胞做事而这种事可能在此时此地并不切实但实际上可能会得到回报的渴望——正如你所说，不仅是为了后代，甚至在来世也是如此。嗯，那些占据主导地位的信仰——世界上最强大的半打信仰——是最擅长做这件事的信仰。
There's a big mistake with climate change because it comes from science, but we assume it just somehow Soaks into us. It's very clear that just hitting people over the head with more and more and more data and graphs isn't working. On my internet feeds, I'm on all of the main scientific feeds. There is a new paper every day that says that not only is it bad but it's worse than we thought and it's extremely extremely serious. So serious actually, we're finding it very hard even to find the words to describe it. That doesn't move people, in fact, actually it tends to push them away. However, if we can understand that there are other things
气候变化存在一个巨大的错误，因为它源自科学，但我们假设它不知怎么地就会渗入我们体内。很明显，只是用越来越多、越来越多的数据和图表去敲打人们是行不通的。在我的社交媒体信息流上，我关注了所有主要的科学信息流。每天都有一篇新论文说，这不仅糟糕，而且比我们想象的还要糟糕，而且极端极端严重。实际上非常严重，以至于我们甚至很难找到词语来描述它。这并不能触动人们，事实上，它往往会把他们推开。然而，如果我们能理解还有其他事情
which bind us together, I think that we can find new language. I think it's also very important to recognize that the divides around climate change are social, not scientific. They're social and political, that the single biggest determinants of whether you accept it or you don't accept it is your political values. And that suggests that the solutions to this are not scientific, they are other than maybe psychology. They are
将我们联系在一起，我认为我们可以找到新的语言。我认为同样非常重要的一点是认识到，围绕气候变化的裂痕是社会的，而不是科学的。它们是社会和政治的，决定你是否接受它的单一最大因素是你的政治价值观。这表明，解决这些问题的方案不是科学的，而是除了心理学之外的其他方案。它们是
cultural. We have to find ways of saying sure. We're going to disagree on things politically, but we have things in common that we all care about that are going to have to bring us together. George Marshall is the author of Don't Even Think About It, why our brains are wired to ignore climate change. George, thank you for joining me today on Hidden Brain. You're very welcome. I enjoyed it. Thank you. The Hidden Brain podcast is produced by Karam Agurk Kalasin, Maggie Penman and Max Nestrak. Special thanks this week to Daniel Schuchin. To continue the conversation about human behavior and climate change, join us on Facebook
文化的。我们必须找到表达的方法，当然。我们在政治上会有分歧，但我们有共同关心的事情，这些事情必将把我们团结在一起。乔治·马歇尔是《想都别想：为什么我们的大脑生来就会忽视气候变化》一书的作者。乔治，谢谢你今天做客 Hidden Brain。不客气。我很享受。谢谢你。Hidden Brain 播客由卡拉姆·阿古尔·卡拉辛、玛吉·彭曼和马克斯·内斯特拉克制作。本周特别感谢丹尼尔·舒钦。要继续探讨人类行为与气候变化，请在 Facebook
and Twitter. If you like this episode, consider giving us a review on iTunes or wherever you listen to your podcasts so others can find us. I'm Shankar Vedathan and this is NPR. you There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
和 Twitter 上加入我们。如果你喜欢这期节目，请考虑在 iTunes 或你收听播客的任何地方给我们写个好评，以便其他人能找到我们。我是香卡·维达姆，这里是 NPR。这个剧集还没有评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可留下面向大家的评论。